loses the fight the Canadian once ago is
a V to learn and he drops down world
champion he'll come out with his flag
he'll rule the world everybody loves it
we know we're gonna get it from him but
when it doesn't work like we did deserve
to lose it wasn't just unlucky what kind
of Indian is at the end of the day it's
winning that's it when you watch joy you
feel the passion I do think I detect a
new kind of level of Canadian coming I'm
sure he's gonna learn from that and
benefit from that long term he's already
good you wait and see what he turns into
let's retake from Canadia will be tough
walls on only a tiny bit of HP Down Goes
Berk follows one shot away okay
the diffuser is his he knows he has
plenty of time almost unwinnable I say
well he proves me wrong
Canadian was once one of the best
Rainbow six siege players in the world
after lifting the sledgehammer at the
very first six Invitational he marked
his name in siege history loses the
fight the Canadian once ago David Alert
and he dropped down particular York
world champion but Canadian isn't just a
great player fans fell in love with him
because he's aggressive explosive and
he's not afraid to let people know that
he thinks he's the best player on the
server
oh [ __ ] with the worst start of the game
you're playing twittg Flint which I feel
like most people would be surprised most
but the main reason I do I I like to
make my teammates live in the game I
don't think like I'm like some badass up
there like yelling at the other team I
just try to be as ridiculous as possible
to keep the spirits up and whatnot I
think that's really what I push for but
after that incredible win at the first
Invitational Canadian never saw the same
kind of success
champions he and evil geniuses pulled
off one of the most incredible chokes in
eSports history at the next Invitational
and they kind of went into freefall
after that are you close to getting the
victory any goes down the win last man
alive is net crops his MP K's on the
floor
it's a1 b3 Canadian to keep his team
alive in the biggest tournament in the
world turning the corner he grabs one on
the mark trying to go in for two against
Fox a on stick Allah will take his two
bullets close range of the diigolet
Eagles in town 1v1 against flag says
everyone new Canadian was a good player
but they just didn't think he could come
through in the clutch
fans loved watching him play but in the
back of their heads they knew she wasn't
gonna win and then be cable watches geo
goes for the plant the sound cue will
give to him the information
a Canadian wasn't giving up he was
getting ready to prove everyone wrong
in September 2019 Canadian joined Space
Station gaming they weren't a bad team
in fact they had made it to the 2019
Invitational but they were an na team
and siege hadn't been na zame since
canadian lifted the hammer all the way
back in 2017 but there was something
exciting about ssj back at the 2019
invitational they got so close to
knocking out g to the eventual champion
takes em Penghu but there's not a lot of
time he has to go for the diffuse but
Kanto is going to play the clock and we
are dangerously close
Bradley knows it look at his face come
on it doesn't matter
g2 is their rampy the impact
he's upset but she to look to repeat and
they punch a ticket to the semi-finals
they were group of insanely skilled
players who had a lack of leadership
they were gods but they needed someone
to point their guns in the right
direction and that's someone was
Canadian
I think SS she's like biggest strength
with prior to me joining back at the
last Invitational basically I think it
was definitely just kind of the
discipline in the style of the team
adding Canadian as the team's new igl
proved to be best s Gees turning point
we didn't have like a main igl and that
was like our problem is we didn't have
somebody to like lead us in that
direction and we needed direction and
it's like we couldn't we can think for
ourselves we can do that but it's like
you need a true leader Troy like he
approached us and everything and it
worked out and I'm so happy down on team
all the pieces were in place for
Canadians comeback he had the right team
the right role the right mindset but it
was all or nothing at the invitational
because if he failed they're leaving eg
it was going to look like the worst
decision he ever made like I I know how
the invitational when I was talking to a
Amara when you when you guys lost and
then you and you took some time before
you came out to see me and he went back
and got ya to make sure you were okay
they're good guys yeah the twenty20
Invitational was a gathering of giants
and SS G's group was stacked with some
of the best talent from Europe and na
but despite the insane level of
competition spacestation gaming left
their group stage opponents in the dust
as Canadian gets a kill on to PI and
this is gonna come down to OS 10 second
push hold hands up with one on two
thinking that in with the trade though
no one's mind goes down thinking Nate
gets the kill Antonella Space Station
gaming haploid stop let's retake from
Canadia will be tough balls on only a
tiny bit of HP down goes Merc
bolos one shot away ok the diffuser is
his he knows he has plenty of time
imagine you gotta be pumped with that
one he'll start to diffuse an SSG
manages to save the round he proves me
wrong second round goes to SSG why am I
so much here I can I'm not there I can
hear him through the wall there's one
not the second the reloads in the plant
coming down right now it needs to be
denied but no it's our champ old fight
and it'll be SSD on that full fight to
take the map and the series SSD tour
through the quarters and the semies
without dropping a game making it to the
upper bracket finals as the only
undefeated team in the tournament but
TSM gave them a harder fight but TSM is
making a difficult forum first flow
through a window frag grenade gets eat
by an 80s we already a bolo looking to
get aggressive gets one and it's a
perfect round
ts out Poage can you stick it he can
into the post plant for SSG and it's all
down to faults for the youngest members
of this SSG squad to try and win this
for this diffuser down they are very
much utility TSM takes SS G's map 1o
despite the loss SSG bounced back dumb
stirring TSM on coastline and taking a
close win on cafe from above leaving
only to up down for TSM Burk being one
of those though boss go up to a quad but
so is Merc and he's gonna go for the ice
but no it's denied by Canadian and Space
Station's still remain unscathed
as they move on to their second half
another one for geo he's down in for
Sherpa Canadian he's still holding the
line that's kill number three on this
run for him
Remy Farley getting some action and Gio
he's been cut off if he goes down that's
Space Station Jamie takes control of the
series and moves into the grand finals
2020 Canadian was back in the grand
finals of the Invitational his
redemption was so close he just had a
one opponent left but that opponent was
out support ninjas in pyjamas would not
be easy to beat they had a ton of
momentum going into the most important
match of the year space Asian gaming
went to the grand finals with the upper
bracket advantage they were only two
maps away from a million dollar grand
prize Canadian there's only two maps
away from Redemption but NIT weren't
going down without a fight
he's taken some damage so he could still
perish there goes the logic bombs and
other kill footages of pyjamas are they
gonna finish this off in flawless
fashion like I said the biggest
advantage that s
she had is now gone flawless round
ninjas in pyjamas take map one Giulio
lumps the head off of bolts he'll head
towards the main stairs one spotted by
main stairs they'll engage at Giulio
picks up a second kill Canadian plating
but nobody's there to watch him
timers out and that's the map NIT were
just one map away from dumb stirring SSG
Canadiens loss was almost guaranteed and
his redemption was fading away but he
wasn't down for the count just yet Bosco
can't get out of there now everybody's
falling it's a 3d one somebody from nip
will need to plant its P nose job to do
that Ram P down below will he be able to
stop this in time he hasn't
control to Major Tom we've taught
ourselves a series that's point for
Space Station a lot of time line and it
will stall out lacking some crucial
utility when we see it one left its
kamikaze and that's it is
base stations we will need a fifth to
settle the score it's a best of one
showdown between Brazil and North
America and that's the first kill for
Space Station looking for another as
they turn in theirs Bosco with yet
another Dino
down plant being attempted by Canadian
folk steps one on the Kamikaze Julia
we'll need to stop this musi takes out
Bosco down he goes and it's newsy the
new member the one before with diffuser
down everything is on the line the most
critical moments in muses career with
SSG thirty seconds away they need to
find one person that's it he'll head in
Space Station gaming or your world
champions
SSG is near perfect performance on Bank
denied at nip the victory and a Canadian
lifted the hammer once again for the
first time in three years
Canadian was once again the best in the
world all the strife he endured all the
heartache all the haters he had to deal
with none of it mattered anymore because
Canadian had finally taken back his
rightful place at the top of Ch thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages